[MUSIC PLAYING]
Google Cloud offers a
first-class experience
for Windows workloads
that can help
you reduce your license costs.
Today, we are going to migrate
and modernize a legacy web
application built on the .NET
Framework to Google Cloud
Platform without
changing the source code.
Doing so can make your apps
more scalable and more reliable
while helping to reduce
operations costs.
We're starting with this
familiar e-commerce shop.
It was built using the .NET
Framework version 2.0 and still
works.
We'll take the existing
application code
and move it to managed SQL
server and Windows containers
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
The original Pet
Shop architecture
is a typical application
deployed on a single VM.
It has two tiers, a presentation
layer which is .NET hosted
on IIS on Windows and a data
layer with four SQL Server
databases deployed
on the same VM.
We want to modernize
the presentation layer
to leverage the scalability
and resiliency of Kubernetes.
By using containers, we
can reduce the footprint
of the application and make it
agile for both day-to-day work
and future development.
But first, we want to
migrate the data layer
to a managed SQL Server using
Cloud SQL for SQL Server.
In the Google Cloud
Console, we'll
create our managed
SQL Server instance.
There are several details
you will need to provide,
such as the name of the instance
and the region you prefer.
Be sure to create your database
instance in the same region
where you will run your
Kubernetes cluster.
Once the instance is created, we
need to migrate the databases.
With Import, we can restore an
existing database backup file.
In this case,
we'll restore a BAK
file we already uploaded
to a Cloud Storage bucket.
We'll select our file,
give it a name, and import.
Once we do this for each of
the four original databases,
we can see the SQL Server
instance and the databases
right here from
the Cloud Console.
With Cloud SQL
for SQL Server, we
can use some of
our favorite tools,
such as Microsoft SQL
Server Management Studio.
We'll need to use SQL
Proxy to help ensure
the connection between
our local machine
and Cloud SQL is secure.
Once SQL Proxy is
installed, we'll
launch it and point to the
instance we just created.
As you can see,
the proxy is saying
it is ready for connections.
We'll use SSMS.
We'll provide
authentication details.
Note that the server
name is localhost--
this is because we
use SQL Proxy, which
abstracts the actual address
of where the server is located.
After this connection
is established,
we can see the databases
and interact with them.
We have now migrated
our data layer to GCP.
That means we can turn our
attention to the presentation
layer and the .NET
web application.
Now, we don't need to change
anything in the existing web
app code.
All we need to do is
create a Docker file.
With Docker, containerization
of our app is just three steps.
First, base off of the
ASP.NET 3.5 base image.
Second, step into the
working directory of IIS.
And third, copy the
content of this application
into the container.
To build the container
image using the Docker file
we just made, we'll
run the command docker
build on a Windows machine
that has Docker CLI installed.
Then, to push this new container
image into the Google Container
Registry, we'll use docker push.
The Google Container
Registry is what
will allow us to reference this
image in a Kubernetes cluster.
Before we deploy the web app,
we need to resolve one issue--
how to allow the web app to
communicate with the databases.
Our new architecture is
built around containers.
We can install the Cloud
SQL Proxy as a sidecar
alongside our web app.
This means that the web
app and Cloud SQL Proxy
will be on the same network,
and this will allow the web app
to communicate with the database
using localhost as a server.
So we'll need to update the
web.config of our web app
so it uses localhost in the
SQL Server connection strings
and then rebuild
our container image
and push it to the
Container Registry.
We'll also build a container
image for the SQL Proxy.
First, we'll need a
SQL Proxy Docker file.
This time, we'll base off
of Microsoft base container
image for Windows
Server 2019 Core,
then add SQL Proxy to that,
and then invoke the proxy
and point it to the
SQL Server instance.
In Docker, we'll build
a container image
and then push this
image into the registry.
We now have two
images, Pet Shop IIS
is the image of
the web application
that was containerized,
and SQL Proxy Sidecar
is the SQL Proxy that allows the
app to connect to the managed
SQL Server.
We'll deploy the application
and the SQL Proxy
on the same Pod in a
Kubernetes cluster.
But first, we need to
provide a YAML file that
describes the state we
want for the containers.
Fortunately, we can use a fairly
standard boilerplate YAML.
The important part
is the node selector,
where we can indicate that we
want to deploy into a Windows
node pool.
This means that
we want to deploy
our containers as Windows
containers running on a Windows
node.
Then we list the containers we
want to deploy, the Pet Shop
IIS and SQL Proxy Sidecar
images we just made.
Finally, we'll expose
this application
using an external IP.
We'll use kubectl to
deploy our containers
and check the status
of our web app.
Apply starts the deployment.
Get services lists the external
IP address of the web app.
Get deployments lists
our deployment, now
living in the cloud.
And get pods list the Pods,
showing that the application is
up and running.
At this point, we've
modernized our web app
into a Kubernetes-managed
app running in Pods with one
container for the .NET app and
a second container for the SQL
Proxy with secure connections
to the managed SQL Server
database.
The advantage of an
architecture like this
is that we can scale to two Pods
with a single kubectl command.
Check the documentation
to get started
and try it out for yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]